on peut être des remarques globale sur
le contexte macro économique dans lequel
s'inscrit ce plfr avant que olivier ne
vous donne davantage de précisions ce
plfr est un plfr de sortie de crise et
de transition s'agit de passer de la
crise économique que nous avons connue
au retour à la normale nous avons
toujours dit avec olivier du soft le
quoi qu'il en coûte est une politique
exceptionnelle justifiée par des
circonstances exceptionnelles
mais dès lors que la croissance est de
retour
il faut sortir du quoi qu'il en coûte
vous le faire progressivement de manière
adaptée mais c'est l'objet de ce projet
de loi de finances rectificatif nous
avons une croissance que nous avons
fixée à 5% pour 2021
c'est une évaluation était prudente au
regard des évaluations internationales
la croissance française est évalué entre
5 25 et 5 8%
suivant les différentes institut
d'observation mais nous maintenons par
souci de prudence et évaluation à 5%
dans ce contexte macroéconomique il faut
rajouter également des poussées
inflationnistes qui sont cohérentes par
rapport au retour de l'activité qui se
traduisent dans vos territoires par des
tensions sur le recrutement et les
tensions sur le prix des matières
premières il faut ajouter également une
remontée cohérente des taux d'intérêt à
10 ans de 10 anticipé puisque nous
avions prévu de hausse de ses taux
d'intérêt en 2021
ils ont pris 50 points de base en six
mois en passant de -0 3 à +0 2 2 sur les
taux à 10 ans dans ce contexte là la
stratégie de sortie de crise se fait une
fois encore de manière ciblée et très
dégressive sur les secteurs qui en ont
le plus besoin
les dernières évaluations de la banque
de france montre très clairement que
c'est le secteur de l'hôtellerie des
cafés de la restauration qui a le plus
souffert de la crise
c'est lui qui a besoin actuellement pour
la compagne dans cette sortie de creeps
c'est pour ça que nous avons décidé de
maintenir de manière dégressive et
adapter un fonds de solidarité pour les
trois prochains mois pour 3 4 milliards
d'euros
une activité partielle pour 6,4
milliards d'euros et les exonérations ou
des allègements de charges pour 4
milliards d'euros
nous avons également prévu des
dispositifs de soutien aux plus fragiles
je pense à l'hébergement d'urgence pour
700 millions d'euros
elle a pris le pouvoir d'achat
défiscalisé à les deux agriculteurs pour
350 millions d'euros ou au pass sport
enfin nous avons hier avec le garde des
sceaux eric dupond-moretti annoncé un
plan de sortie de crise pour les
entreprises fragilisées par la crise et
qui reste viable avec un système de
détection et d'alerté précoce un
accompagnement financier sous forme de
quasi fonds propres avec un fonds de
transition doté de 3 milliards d'euros
et les procédures accélérées sur trois
mois au lieu des 6 à 8 mois qu'ils sont
en général nécessaire
nous avons également déplafonné et
étendu sur trois exercices
le dispositif de report des pertes la
dispute et de carry-back qui permet de
soulager la trésorerie des entreprises
et qui était extrêmement demandée par
beaucoup d'entreprises
enfin je tiens à indiquer que sur le
plus long terme
deux questions vont se poser la première
c'est évidemment le rétablissement des
finances publiques nous avons 9 4% de
déficit et 117 pour semble dette
publique
je veux juste rappeler que nous avions
su le faire avant la crise en sortant en
trois ans la france de la procédure pour
déficit public excessif et en la
ramenant sous les 3% de déficit
il faudra le moment venu quand la
croissance sera de retour revenir aussi
à ses équilibres des finances publiques
pour nous permet de disposer des
réserves nécessaires en cas de nouvelle
crise où de nouveaux chocs sanitaires la
deuxième question sur laquelle nous
aurons peut-être l'occasion de revenir
c'est le niveau de croissance que nous
voulons lendemain de la crise nous
aurons rattraper sans doute au premier
trimestre 2010 22 en tout cas c'est
notre objectif
le niveau d'activité économique que nous
avions avant la crise
mais ce niveau d'activité avant la crise
se caractérise et dans tous les pays
européens
par une croissance potentielle plus
faibles que celles dont disposent
notamment nos partenaires américains et
la chine donc la question est de savoir
si des investissements supplémentaires
sont nécessaires pour accroître la
croissance potentielle de la france au
lendemain de la crise c'est une question
qui est je crois mérite d'être posée et
que nous avons posée auprès de nos
partenaires européens
il ya dix jours à lisbonne au sommet des
ministres des finances et que nous
continuerons à soulever avec le
président de la république
merci à madame la présidente monsieur
messieurs bruno metsu rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
qu'elles comprennent d'abord pour dire
madame la présidente que décret d'avancé
a été présenté aux transmis aux deux
assemblées le 11 mai
nous avions effectivement indiqué que
les assemblées serait saisi d'un projet
de loi de finances rectificatif dans les
semaines qui suivent pourquoi est-ce que
cela intervient ainsi tôt en tout cas à
vos yeux
car nous savons que les contraintes
liées au calendrier parlementaire d'une
part et les délais classique d'examen
font que même avec une présentation au
site au début du mois de juin
nous ne pouvons espérer une adoption et
encore moins une plus publication du
projet de loi de finances rectificatif
avant la mi juillet et donc c'est à ce
moment là que le besoin de crédit sera
le plus pressant c'est la raison pour
laquelle le calendrier a été ainsi
retenu je voudrais simplement souligné
ou octo évoqué les trois séries de
mesures qui conquit composés qui font le
plfr que nous vous présentons avec bruno
le maire aujourd'hui la première série
de mesures concernent des mesures
d'urgence cela a été évoqué avec la
volonté de recharger les crédits
nécessaires au financement de l'activité
partielle pour 6 milliards 400 millions
d'euros le fonds de solidarité pour 3
milliards 4 auquel nous ajoutons 150
millions d'euros de dispositifs
spécifiques au secteur de la culture et
4 milliards d'euros pour la compensation
des exonérations de cotisations de
l'état au profit la sécurité sociale
nous proposons aussi au parlement
d'ouvrir une provision d'eau sous la
forme d'une dotation pour des dépenses
accidentelle est imprévisible
la hauteur d'1 5 milliard d'euros
l'objectif d'un objectif de prudence
puisque si les indicateurs économiques
sont bons et si les indicateurs
sanitaires sont bons aussi
nous préférons prévoir cette possibilité
cette réserve de précaution au cas où
une dégradation sur yon viendrai pardon
au cours de l'été à un moment où
évidemment nous ne pourrions réunir le
parlement pour solliciter l'ouverture de
crédits le deuxième clip s'appelle fr
deuxième bloc de mesures répondent à des
besoins que nous finançons ou vise à
financer des décisions qui ont été
annoncées il en est ainsi pour la
question de l'hébergement de
l'hébergement d'urgence puisque le
maintien des capacités d'hébergement
d'urgence à un niveau extrêmement élevé
pendant toute la période estivale alors
qu'habituellement le nombre de places en
hébergement d'urgence baisse avec la
période estivale représente un coût de
700 millions d'euros que nous proposons
d'inscrire avec ce plfr nous vous
proposons aussi de voter 350 millions
d'euros de crédits au profit de
l'agriculture avec une première tranche
d'indemnisation à la suite de l'épisode
de gel du début du mois d'avril mais
aussi la volonté de répondre et de
financer un certain nombre de besoins en
matière d'indemnisation et de doutes
quant à la grippe aviaire johnny's la
betterave dead au brutal et ont autant
de décisions qui ont été annoncés et que
nous vous proposons de financer ainsi il
est aussi proposé d'inscrire 100
millions d'euros pour financer le
passeport annoncé par le président de la
république et les quelques jours 82
millions d'euros pour aider et
accompagner la nouvelle calédonie 57
millions d'euros pour des actions mises
en place dans le cadre des quartiers
prioritaires de la politique de la ville
et 150 millions d'euros pour faire face
à une augmentation des besoins en
matière de bourses sur critères sociaux
pour l'enseignement supérieur et ainsi
permettre au ministère de faire face à
ses engagements
ces dépenses nouvelles représentent un
milliard quatre cent cinquante millions
d'euros elle ne creuse pas le déficit de
l'état dans la mesure où nous les avons
engagé à la fois en diminuant pour 995
millions d'euros les crédits consacrés
aux appels de garanties pour le pg e
nous savons pouvoir diminuer ses crédits
en appel de garantie
d'abord parce que le report de la
première échéance possible de choix
repousse au delà de 2021
beaucoup des risques de sinistralité
mais surtout parce que le risque de
sinistralité est beaucoup moins
important que nous craignons et nous
pensons qu'ils sont même convaincus
retirer 990 15 millions d'euros est
possible il est aussi procédé à
l'annulation de 460 millions d'euros de
crédits crédits qui était déjà gelé au
titre de la réserve de précaution
je rappelle qu'il est égal à 3 % des
crédits ouverts ou l'avoir ramené à 3%
après plusieurs années autour de 7 à 8%
de réserve de précaution nous avons
veillé à ne pas solliciter des
programmes partir il a man prioritaire
je pense notamment au programme
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
nous avons aussi veiller à ce que ce gel
cette annulation pardon de crédits gelés
n'ai aucune conséquence sur les
programmes et des actions engagées par
les ministères à titre d'illustration
pour le ministère de la justice
l'annulation d'une partie de la réserve
que nous vous proposons maintien au
niveau des crédits disponibles nettement
au dessus de ce qui était prévu en loi
de programmation de la justice et donc
c'est la démonstration que cette ces
annulations ne viennent pas contrarier
la mise en oeuvre de projets 3e série de
mesures d'une part des mesures qui ont
évidemment un caractère budgétaire mais
qui n'ont pas d' influence ou d'impact
sur le déficit au sens masse mes chiens
du terme
nous vous proposons ainsi d'autoriser la
pe engagé pour deux milliards d'euros
supplémentaires
nous vous proposons de renforcer le
budget annexe dédiée au contrôle aérien
à hauteur de 200 millions d'euros pour
faire face aux difficultés longue et
forte du secteur aéronautique et nous
vous proposons aussi d'abonder hauteur
de 600 millions d'euros le fonds de
développement économique et social revue
remaniée qui devient fonds de transition
permettant de financer et d'accompagner
les entreprises dans le cadre du plan
anti faillite tel qu'il a été présenté
par bruno le maire pas plus tard qu'hier
enfin nous avons des dispositifs de
l'être avec la possibilité pour les
entreprises de souscrire des pg e
jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2021 et non
pas jusqu'au 30 juin
avec la reconduction de la prime
spéciale de pouvoir d'achat
défiscalisées et exonérées de
cotisations sociales pour la troisième
année consécutive et avec des critères
très identiques à ceux de l'année
dernière nous avons le dispositif de
carry-back qui a été évoqué et qui
permet d'accompagner les entreprises
ayant réalisé des pertes et nous aurons
effectivement à vous proposer un
dispositif de prise en charge et de
prise en compte des pertes enregistrées
par un certain nombre de régies beaucoup
des régies des services publics en régie
ont pu être accompagnés soit au titre
des mécanismes de protection des
collectivités soit il de l'activité
partielle selon leur mode d'organisation
certaines régies par leur organisation
par le fait de mobiliser des agents de
droit public alors qu'elles ont une
activité activités qui relèvent des
speak n'ont pu être aidés et donc vous
proposons de pallier cette difficulté de
pallier ce manque et ainsi de pouvoir
mobiliser des crédits est un dispositif
pour les accompagner l'ensemble de ces
dispositions a évidemment un coût
même si nous avons engagé avec les
dépenses qui relève des crédits
ordinaires des ministères les 15
milliards les 15 points 5 milliards
d'euros au titre des mesures d'urgence
se traduisent par un alourdissement les
aggravations du déficit de l'état
j'ai eu l'occasion de préciser que
celui-ci passé de 173 milliards d'euros
quand il est fier à 213 milliards
d'euros à l'issue du plfr s'il était
adopté dans les termes dans lesquels
nous vous le présentons cette
augmentation du déficit de l'état
s'explique de façon à la fois par les 15
points 5 milliards d'euros de mesures
nouvelles
mais aussi par une intégration la prise
en compte des 28 8 milliards d'euros de
mesures d'urgence non dépensés en 2020
du fait d'une situation économique moins
dégradée que craint tout près cliquera
ont prévu et donc l'inscription ses 28
milliards d'euros ajoutés aux 15
milliards d'euros que nous vous
proposons d'inscrire avec le plfr
explique cette dégradation
dans le même temps la révision du niveau
d'une chine du niveau du pib de 2020 la
révision du niveau de récession à 7,9
plutôt que les 8,2 et les derniers
chiffres apportés par l'insee ont un
effet que je qualifierais
certainement incorrectement de contra
cyclique ce qui explique qu'avec la
dégradation du budget du déficit de
l'état que j'ai évoqués nous avons une
dégradation du déficit public de 9 4% et
0 4 peuvent sembler peu par rapport aux
montants concernés par le déficit de
l'état mais je le répète il ya des
mouvements contraires qui explique cette
variation de seulement si je puis dire
0.4 point enfants le poids de la dette
publique est à 117,2 % là aussi une
manière peut-être contre intuitive il
est désormais moins important que dans
le mode finance initiale où il était
prévu à 117 10 % mais nous avons aussi
un effet numérateur par la révision à la
baisse du taux de récession de l'année
2020 et par les chiffres de l'insee est
elle qui nous ont été communiqués
le 28 mai sur les trois dernières années
ceci étant dit lorsque nous affichons un
déficit public à 9 4% et une dette à
117,2 % cela ouvre évidemment un des
bars et des perspectives sur la
nécessité de redresser les comptes
publics la nécessité de sortir du coin
qu'il en coûte en même temps que de
l'épidémie de manière progressive mais
de manière certaine pour retrouver un
niveau plus soutenable de dépenses
publiques voilà ce que je pouvais dire
madame la pression merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre j'ai noté avec
attention toutes les ouvertures de
crédit que vous avez évoquées il me
semble que vous n'êtes pas venu sur
n'est pas précisé la raison de
l'ouverture de 1,9 milliard de crédit
sur la mission engagement financier de
l'état donc et je pense que nous serons
très attentifs en tout cas je suis
contente d'entendre que vous venez
déposer un dispositif de type carry-back
puisque le sénat l'a fait déjà voté lors
des lois de finances rectificatif en
2020 donc nous sommes de temps en temps
attendu peut-être un peu trop tard sans
plus tarder je cède la parole au
rapporteur général
merci madame la présidente merci
messieurs les ministres
ja voir pour une fois cinq questions
deux courtes sur le plan de relance et
proies question évidemment sur le plfr
sur le plan de relance je voudrais
savoir sur quoi portent les annulations
de crédits de plus de 500 millions
d'euros 534 millions d'euros exactement
sur le programme eco logis de la mission
plan de relance connaissez mon
attachement au sujet et pour dire
également que la cour des comptes a
estimé les décaissements effectués au
titre du plan de relance en 2020 à 4
milliards 8 à combien se situe le niveau
de décaissement pour 2021
aujourd'hui à ce stade de l'année
concernant le plfr il y a un nom
troisième projet de loi de finances
rectificative il était déposée le 10
juin 2020 et il prévoyait à l'époque
déjà un déficit budgétaire de 222
milliards d'euros c'est-à-dire très
proche des 219 milliards présentée
aujourd'hui ce montant me semblait à
l'époque déjà très surestimé malgré et
malgré la dégradation de la situation
sanitaire de l'automne 2020 le déficit
budgétaire s'est élevé au final à 173
milliard d'euros quels éléments
pouilloux apporter pour justifier qu'il
n'en sera pas de même cette année et que
notamment les ouvertures de crédits ne
seront pas très supérieure aux besoins
réels
ou alors est-ce une enveloppe de
précaution la présidente du jour vient
d'évoquer s'agissant du plfr le fait que
le sénat avait proposée et adoptée à
deux reprises le dispositif de
carry-back donc de report en arrière des
déficits et à l'époque le
ministre olivier du soft avait expliqué
qu' il s'y opposait parce que c'est
représenter un coût extrêmement
important alors j'ai entendu que le
ministre bruno le maire
quand j'irai lui que c'était extrêmement
demandés donc si vous pouvez au delà de
la sémantique nous expliquer ce qui vous
a amené sachant que a modifié la vo
votre position peut-être est-ce le fait
que la commission européenne a
recommandé récemment aux états membres
de recourir davantage à ce mécanisme
doit-on penser dans ce cas qu'il eût été
préférable d'être à la commission
européenne qu'au sénat puisque
effectivement nous l'avions adoptée à
deux reprises enfin dernière question
concernant le plfr et la prolongation
des pg e du 30 juin au 31 décembre de
cette année c'est la concrétisation
d'une annonce faite
et comme vous le savez j'ai présenté
récemment un rapport de sortie dp jeu
que le ministre évidemment reçu c'est
logique
lors de la présentation g2 qui a été
fait hier matin j'ai pu constater qu'on
avait en fait un diagnostic assez
analogue sur la situation et les besoins
des entreprises avec une approche un
triptyque identifié orienté traités et
vous reprenez également un certain
nombre de ses recommandations vous
l'avez d'ailleurs redit et notamment
celle qui vise à organiser finalement eu
une une cellule à comité partenarial de
financement des entreprises en sortie de
crise
à l'échelon départemental et au delà des
seuls acteurs publics sous l'autorité du
préfet je m'en félicite en tout les cas
je souhaite que ça fonctionne au mieux
j'avais également demandé est proposé
d'introduire un mécanisme fiscal de
déductions pour le capital à risque
visant justement à neutraliser le biais
de l'endettement pour mieux vous
convaincre et peut-être gagner du temps
par rapport à l'épisode convient
d'évoquer de carry-back je veux rappeler
que ce dispositif est également
recommandée par le fmi et la commission
européenne puisque ce plfr ne comporte
rien à ce sujet pourquoi monsieur le
ministre une l'envisagez-vous pas et
question subsidiaire mais in
désintéressé verriez-vous d'un oeil
favorable le dépôt d'un tel amendement
merci je vous propose peut-être de
prendre les questions des orateurs qui
se sont inscrits de manière à a donné la
possibilité au ministre le maire de
pouvoir répondre avant qu'ils doivent
s'éclipser pour une autre contrainte
donc bernard delcros puis sylvie
vermeillet oui merci madame la
présidente
mais ces messieurs les ministres moi je
voudrais revenir rapidement ça vous
étonnera pas sur la question de la prise
en compte des pertes de recettes attaché
aux régies sujet de qui a fait largement
débat dans le cadre du plf puisque le
plf avec 1m créé une disparité entre les
collectivités
souvent les plus grosses d'ailleurs qui
ont géré leurs services dans le cadre
d'une délégation de service public et
dont le délégataire pouvez bénéficier
des aides accordées au secteur privé et
les collectivités souvent les plus
petites qui elles ont géré leurs
services en régie ce quelle que soit la
forme de la régie et qui n'ont pas pu
bénéficier des aides dont je suis
vraiment heureux et je sais que je suis
pas seul que ce set projet de loi de
finances rectificative et où là il a
annoncé prenne en compte cette question
des régies donc moi j'aurai quelques
questions précises à ce sujet si j'ai
bien compris dans le mécanisme de
compensation on prendrait en compte
l'écart entre l'épargné brute 2019 et
l'épargné brute 2020 donc mes questions
sur les suivantes
est ce qu'il s'agit des budgets annexes
j'ai cru comprendre que la prise en
compte concernerait au c'est bien aussi
bien les régies qui serait organisée
dans le cadre d'un service public
industriel et commercial que dans ce cas
d'un service public administratif
est-ce qu'il s'agit bien de l'écart
d'épargné brute des budgets annexes et
que ce pastis et le cas que se
passe-t-il pour les régies et elles sont
nombreuses dans les plus petites
communes qui ne font pas l'objet d'un
budget annexe et dans les dépenses et
les recettes sont intégrés au budget
général et puis dernier poème dans le
rapport qui nous a été communiqué on
indique que sont exclus de la dotation
lorsque les situations suivantes lorsque
les dépenses réelles de fonctionnement
de l'année 2019 de la régie était super
de 50% aux recettes réelles de
fonctionnement de la même année dans les
territoires les moins denses les
services publics gérés en régie sont
très souvent déficitaires
je pense aux piscines au centre
aqualudique des petits territoires
est-ce à dire que pour les services qui
aurait été déficitaire les années
précédentes et qu'il serait bien sûr
davantage dans le cadre de la crise de
suite à la fermeture ses services il n'y
aurait pas de prise en compte
voilà donc je voudrais avoir quelques
éléments sur ces questions là merci
s'élevant et pensez vous que la somme
qui est affecté à la prise en compte des
pertes de recettes des services ti en
régie est suffisant merci si l'hiver
mais y est certainement pour rebondir
sur le même sujet oui mais ce n'est pas
seulement madame la présidente
oui alors effectivement moins j'exprime
à ma grande satisfaction sur le fait que
l'état ait entendu la cause des régies
celle qui gère donc des services
notamment avec des contrats de droit
public et qui vont pouvoir bénéficier de
l'accompagnement de l'aide de l'état
évidemment je pensais plus
particulièrement originaire mal on s'en
était fait l'écho à plusieurs reprises
dans mon département du jura il ya une
une situation il ya quand même 400
emplois qui sont en jeu et je ne peux
qu'exprimer ma grande satisfaction de
voir l'état aux côtés de de ces
municipalités
monsieur le maire pour rebondir sur vos
propos ce plfr qui est sortie de crise
et qui est une transition
et pour atteindre un taux de croissance
proche de 5%
il me semble qu'il ya un certain nombre
de deux paramètres qui se met en place
avec cette sortie de crise la hausse du
coût des matières premières la hausse du
coût de l'énergie
et puis pour faire face à cette reprise
est bien les entreprises dans partout
j'imagine en tout cas c'est aussi le cas
chez moi
on commence à avoir des problèmes de
recrutement des problèmes de main
d'oeuvre et pour ça il faut sans doute
adapter l'offre de formation je sais que
vous y être sensible que vous êtes
penché sur la question mais
il se trouve que il y à des entreprises
qui pour pouvoir aspirer cette pompe de
la croissance met en place elle même des
formations parce qu'elles ne sont pas
satisfaites par par l'offre de formation
actuelle est que même dans ces cas là
elles ont du mal à boucler leur
formation à trouver du personnel pour
pouvoir former et du coup alimenté en
main d'oeuvre la leur entreprise et donc
la reprise
une question peut être plus difficile
qui serait celle des fonderies g
l'entreprise mbf dans le jura manzoni
bouchot fonderie il s'agit forcément
d'une d'une transition elle est
nécessaire je pense que là la crise est
un accélérateur de transition les
entreprises
même hors crise qu vide c'est entre 7
ses fonderies l on aurait dû s'en doute
s'adapter mais peut-être plus avec plus
de délai pour le faire la crise accélère
cette transition et l'état les
accompagne
comment est ce que vous pensez conduire
et accompagner cette accélération parce
que les choses du coup vont encore plus
vite pour l'état comment est ce que vous
pensez faire je pense que l'état avec
cette crise sanitaire a fait du cousu
main pour tout un tas de branches de
l'économie est là pour certains secteurs
qui mécaniquement doivent s'adapter
moi je me pose la question de savoir si
l'état saura faire du cousu main aussi
pour ces entreprises tous ces fleurons
de notre industrie qui sont obligées de
s'adapter mais pour lesquels on n'a pas
vraiment de solution dernier petit point
monsieur le ministre vous avez parlé de
l'éventualité d'une croissance
supplémentaire de la france
moi je pense qu'il ya une réserve de
croissance qui résident dans les
collectivités
je sais que olivier dussopt qui ne
partagent pas forcément ce que je dis
mais s'ils ont dopé la detr il est
certain que les collectivités saurait
développer d'autres projets et il me
semble que la d2 terre est insuffisante
aujourd'hui pour répondre à tous les
projets des collectivités
merci merci
et donc je vais prendre une dernière
question pour cette première série
puisque la liste s'allonge donc si vous
pouvez essayer d'être concis parce que
sinon j'ai peur ça nous emmène loin dans
la soirée donc la parole est à vincent
capo-canellas ce merci on a la
présidente questions brèves une question
sur le contexte économique s'agissant de
la poussées inflationnistes et de la
remontée des taux d'intérêt qu'elle est
votre prévision et comment
appréciez-vous l'impact qu'elles peuvent
avoir sur l'activité et sur nos comptes
publics
messieurs le maire vous comment celle ci
alors sur les questions du rapporteur
général sur le carry back pour la raison
principale pour lesquelles nous avons
adopté le karabakh c'est bien sûr que le
sénat l'a proposé tous n'ont pas d'avoir
la commission européenne nous écoutons
d'abord les sénateurs qui connaissent
mieux la réalité du terrain que la
commission européenne la réalité c'est
que c'est une excellente mesure vous
pouvez le répéter c'est une excellente
mesure mais en même temps il est 10 oct
l'avait signalé c'était une mesure qui
est coûteuse et qui donc de peut-être
réserver quelle période très
particulière qui est celle du
redémarrage de l'activité
les mesures qui est saine
fondamentalement parce qu' elle ne
touche pas aux résultats des entreprises
elle permet simplement d'avoir cette
déduction sur la base des pertes passées
donc nous avons pris la décision parce
que l'économie redémarre de retenir
cette proposition du sénat pour un coût
qui est évalué à environ 400 millions
d'euros par an en trésorerie pour l'état
400 millions d'euros par an en
trésorerie pour l'état donc même si
c'est de trésorerie ce sont des chiffres
qui sont importants le chiffre exact
dépendra évidemment du montant exact de
la perte de 2020 nous n'avons pas encore
l'étalement se fera sur 2017 2018 2019
et le plafond qui était de 1 million
d'euros sera supprimé pour donner
vraiment tout c'est depuis sa puissance
à cette mesure
l'objectif est bien d'avoir une mesure
très puissante au moment du redémarrage
de l'économie
s'agissant des paies jeu là aussi nous
avons retenu la plupart les propositions
du rapport de jean-françois husson qui
est un excellent apport
et qui permet effectivement de valider
la prolongation du pg e au 31 décembre
et d'avoir dans le cadre de procédures
judiciaires je le rappelle la
possibilité d'un étalement plus long
tout en maintenant la garantie de l'état
je veux juste bien précisé que cette
possibilité d'étendre la maturité des
prêts garantis par l'état au delà de 6
ans se fait exclusivement sous le
contrôle est juste dans le cadre de
procédures judiciaires mais sur la base
des recommandations du rapport de
jean-françois husson nous avons obtenu
de la commission européenne que dans ce
cadre là la garantie de l'état soit
maintenue donc c'est pour beaucoup
d'entreprises
je pense un vrai soulagement je rappelle
également pour qu'on remette bien les
choses decker que nous n'avons pas
d'inquiétude particulière sur les
niveaux de dette des entreprises ont
pris les dispositions nécessaires pour
faire face à la situation qui arrive
évitons de donner le montant la babe
ruth
il est 220 milliards d'euros dettes
supplémentaires dus à la crise
il faut mettre en regard de cette dette
brute l'augmentation de la trésorerie
des entreprises qui s'élève à 212
milliards d'euros parce qu'en fait
beaucoup d'entreprises ont pris des pg e
ont mis de l'argent de côté et donc la
dette nette
l'augmentation de la dette nette mais
que de 9 milliards d'euros
donc ça ça ramène à de justes
proportions la réalité du problème
financier auxquelles sont confrontées
les entreprises quant à la proposition
de déductions fiscales pour le capital à
risque pour les entreprises
je crois que la mesure carry-back va
permettre justement d'opérer une
déduction des pertes sur les bénéfices
fiscaux donc c'est une forme de
déduction fiscale à laquelle s'ajoutent
je rappel de mesures structurelles que
nous avons prise avec le président de la
république est prêt ministre la baisse
du taux d'impôt sur les sociétés
nous n'avons pas changé la trajectoire
de baisse 10 aces qui sera ramené à 25%
pour toutes les entreprises en 2022 et
la baisse de 10 milliards d'euros des
impôts de production je constate avec
plaisir que cette proposition de baisse
des impôts de production et qui faisait
débat lorsque le gouvernement l'a
proposé il y a deux ou trois ans
maintenant fait florès
quasiment déborder sur les propositions
de baisse d'impôts de production tant
mieux c'est la preuve que finalement
chacun fait son chemin de damas et que
les propositions du gouvernement
rencontre un assentiment de plus en plus
générale s'agissant des régies je
laisserais olivier 10 oct répondre sur
les remarques faites par sylvie vermeil
je partage totalement ce que vous avez
dit sur le problème de formation c'est
un problème absolument clé il faut dans
des délais beaucoup plus rapide que ce à
quoi nous sommes habitués accompagner
les salariés pour aller vers de nouveaux
métiers
donc c'est tout l'objectif du dispositif
qui est mis en place elisabeth bornes
mais ce soyons honnêtes la rapidité des
révolutions technologiques nous surprend
tout ça il ya encore quelques mois on se
disait bon et rend un équilibre entre le
thermique et les véhicules électriques
ou hybrides rechargeables qui va
s'opérer dans les années qui viennent
la réalité c'est que la rupture
technologique est beaucoup plus rapide
que seront rendus au cours des 12
derniers mois
plus le véhicule hybride rechargeable
que de véhicule thermique diesel
donc vous voyez bien que la bascule se
fait de manière extrêmement rapide voire
brutale donc ça nous oblige nous
responsables publics à accélérer ces
dispositifs transformation et
d'accompagnement est derrière cette
touche effectivement des entreprises
très concrètement je vous cite et la
fonderie de mbf dans le jura nous avons
pris à bras le corps ce problème des
fonderies j'ai organisé il y a
maintenant près peu plus d'un mois une
réunion de l'ensemble des constructeurs
automobiles et les sous traitants
automobiles sur le sujet spécifique des
fonderies c'était d'ailleurs une
proposition de la cgt
vous voyez que nous ne sommes pas
discriminant sur les propositions et sur
leur origine la proposition des vtt fait
par la cgt je pense que c'est une bonne
proposition de regarder l'intégralité
des fonderies en france il représente
quasiment quinze mille emplois de voir
comment est ce qu'on les accompagne
comment est-ce qu'on est transforme
comment est-ce qu'on diversifient leurs
activités de façon à ce que l'on puisse
sauver le maximum d'emplois
mais il faut être très clair les
fonderies françaises ont un problème de
compétitivité
et ça on peut pas tourner autour du pot
il faut le prendre à bras le corps elles
ne peuvent pas se reposer uniquement sa
fabrication de moteurs thermiques
puisque par définition ces mots t on va
te remplacer par des moteurs électriques
mais ils peuvent avoir parce qu'ils ont
de la qualité du savoir-faire des
diversifications possible exemple les
produits en fonte pour le nucléaire
moi je considère que l'énergie nucléaire
fait partie de l'avenir edinger tic
français je considère que le nucléaire
est un atout pour la france
je considère que la maîtrise du cycle et
de l'intégralité du site est un élément
de puissance d'autres nations et je
considère que dans une période qui
s'ouvre on va voir encore plus besoin
d'électricité avant la capacité de
produire d'électricité décarbonée à
partir de centrales nucléaires c'est un
atout pour la france
et je pense que c'est bien chacun prenne
position là dessus mais et tous ceux qui
sont opposés au nucléaire qui veulent
accélérer les fermetures m'expliqueront
où ils trouveront l'électricité peu
coûteuse décarbonés disponibles dont
nous aurons besoin aussi bien pour nos
smartphones pour nos téléphones
portables pour la domotique que pour nos
véhicules électriques est évidemment le
président me retire les mots de la
bouche pour la production d'hydrogène et
pour l'électro liste qui réclame
beaucoup d'énergie vous connaissez ma
position là dessus je les rappelle avec
sincérité franchise et partez
merci madame la présidente quelques
quelques mots d'abord pour dire au
rapporteur général que le redéploiement
de 500 millions d'euros deux mots sein
de la mission relance tarifs le
déploiement qui sera l équilibre nous
retirons 500 millions d'euros programme
écologie pour le flécher sur le
programme compétitivité sans remettre en
cause le caractère vert du plan de
relance dans son équilibre est par
ailleurs au sein du pays a le procès
dans un mouvement inverse ce qui
renforce encore la question de l'
équilibre pourquoi est ce que nous
procédons à ce mouvement avec un
équilibre dans le cadre de l' enveloppe
de 100 milliards d'euros pour garantir
le financement et la trésorerie de
financement d'un certain nombre de
mesures que nous allons rouvrir ou quand
nous avons rouvert
je pense notamment aux mesures en
matière de territoire de démesure
territoire d'industrie industries du
futur numérisation des pme nous avons
aussi des mouvements mais qui passeront
par voie réglementaire puisque
législatives pour par exemple assurer le
financement et le rip de décaissement de
ma prime rennes en tout cas le caractère
vert du temps de relance n'est
absolument pas altéré par ce mouvement
de crédit sur une augmentation de la
charge de la dette de 1,9 milliard
d'euros
c'est évidemment en lien avec tensions
inflationnistes que nous connaissons
déjà insiste sur le lien avec les
tensions inflationnistes puisque même si
les taux auxquels la france emprunte
sont légèrement plus haut par rapport à
ce que nous avons connu il ya quelques
mois c'est avant tout l'inflation que
nous connaissons les uns les autres qui
est connu de tous qui se traduit en
termes d'indexation par une augmentation
de la charge de la dette d'un milliard
neuf je précise et cela a été rappelé
tout à l'heure pour miser l'économie que
dans le cadre de la loi de finances pour
nous avions prévu un retour des taux
autour de 0 3%
nous sommes aujourd'hui à 0,2 nous
étions au début de l'année à moins 0,2
mais à ce stade nous sommes toujours
dans le cas de la prévision qui avaient
été considérées comme prudentes mais qui
pour le coup s'avère efficace et et sage
sur les questions relatives aux origines
nous allons effectivement indemnisés la
perte d'épargné brute entre 2019 et 2020
des régions industrielles et
commerciales organisées en budgets
annexes ainsi que des régies organisé un
service public administratif
quand c'est nécessaire elles sont moins
nombreuses pour le coup nous allons
faire en sorte d'accompagner aussi les
services publics industriels et
commerciaux mais qui très généralement
sûr que sont organisées en budgets
annexes
nous avons encore quelques paramètres à
travailler par voie réglementaire
donc il faudra qu'on regarde la question
de l'absence au nombre des budgets
annexes c'est la règle des 50 % et donc
l'inéligibilité à l'aide lorsque les
dépenses sont égales sont supérieurs à
50% en recettes c'est une contrainte
liée au régime des aides d'état au
niveau communautaire dont nous pourrons
nous affranchir nous allons par contre
regardez dans le cadre du débat comment
certaines régies qui ont confié leurs
services à des délégataires ça arrive
parfois que la régie dans le cadre de
son organisation est ensuite recourent à
une dsp pour être accompagnées
généralement les dsp ont fait les
délégataires ont été accompagnés par les
régimes classiques des deux entreprises
on a deux trois exemples où il peut y
avoir des dix tendances donc nous sommes
en train d'y travailler avec jacqueline
gourault sur l'aide à l'investissement
des collectivités la d2 terme
c'est un prisonnier connaît ma position
mais c'est surtout un rappel en 2015
l'adie s'il n'existait pas et là des
notaires s'élevait à 660 millions
d'euros par an depuis 2000 15 l'adultère
est à un milliard d'euros par an il ya
des sites aussi un milliard d'euros par
an et nous avons ajouté un milliard de
dhs et s'il relance au mois d'août 2020
et un milliard à 950 millions d'euros de
dettes il rénove avec de la vatine ans
pour 2021 en veillant temps pour la ds
il relance doute 2020 que pour la d6 le
rénove de janvier 2021
parce que les critères d'éligibilité à
cette tranche d'aidé s'il soit aligné
sur les critères de la des cils habituel
et de la bio taire pour ne pas écarter
les petites communes du bénéfice de
cette tranche supplémentaire des cils
donc c'est une multiplication par an et
demi des aides consenties par l'état aux
communes et aux intercommunalités pour
l'investissement puisque habituellement
depuis 2015 nous étions à 1 2 milliard
et
cela a été trois l'année dernière et 3
cette année il faudrait ajouter d'autres
dispositifs du plan de relance et il me
semble que les dispositifs de soutien à
l'investissement des collectivités sont
aujourd'hui un niveau qui a un caractère
exceptionnel mais qui nous paraît
suffisant surtout quand on garde en tête
le fait que l'épargné brute des
connectivités en 2020 s'est établi à 31
milliards 5 ce qui reste le même niveau
mais 2018 donc à un niveau plutôt là
aussi très favorable et très
encourageant pour la suite
sur les autres questions je crois avoir
fait le tour en tout cas bruno le maire
les a évoqué simplement dire au
rapporteur général qu en 2020 nos
prévisions avait été prudent je rappelle
que nous avions proposé au parlement de
budgéter de quoi faire face à une
situation de confinement pendant deux
mois sur novembre et décembre avec une
hypothèse de perte d'activité de 20
points par mois le confinement de
novembre s'est traduit par une perte
d'activité d'à peu près dans ce point le
couvre-feu de descendre par une perte
d'activité autant 7 points ce qui
explique le décalage entre ce qui a été
consommé
et ce qui avait été voté nous avons
reporté ses crédits et nous les
mobilisons nous vous proposons
d'inscrire des crédits pour financer la
sortie progressive des aides
nous pensons avoir inscrit le juste
montant des crédits mais je ne vous
cache pas que si une reprise d'activité
plus rapide et une croissance forte au
cours d'année 2021 a mené l'économie a
moins sollicité les mesures d'urgence et
donc qu'est-ce que ces crédits ne soient
pas tous consommé ça serait une double
bonne nouvelle
une bonne nouvelle pour l'économie en
général et une bonne nouvelle aussi pour
les finances publiques donc nous pensons
être dans la juste prévisions mais si je
devais choisir je préférerais une
sous-consommation à une surconsommation
pour les raisons que jamais bloquée
merci monsieur les ministres pour cette
ses premières réponses alors vous êtes
encore dix intervenants vouloir prendre
la parole donc si vous voulez des
réponses des ministres des deux
ministres je vous invite à être vraiment
qu'on s'y dans vos questions marc
laménie commence il sera suivi par
antoine lefèvre merci madame la
présidente
merci messieurs les les ministres
questions sur lequel monsieur du soft
venez de répondre je vous souhaitez vous
interroger sur le plan de relance
soutient l'investissement des
collectivités territoriales qui sont
réellement des donneurs d'ordre
important pour la relance alors le
secteur relance du bâtiment et des
travaux publics
donc c'était un petit peu mes
interrogations à ce niveau là parce que
il ya des beaucoup d'entreprises qui
sont fortement impactées sel et cela a
été rappelé et donc dans le plan de
relance au niveau du secteur btp est
alors certes
la detr
reste stable
dans le département que je leur présente
les ardennes en tout cas même si un
niveau constant
la d6 louis la décide il ya un certain
nombre de projets qui sont financés mais
je dirais y at il pas moyen de
simplifier un peu l'attribution de la
décision puisque c'est une enveloppe
régionale par par grandes régions voilà
c'était un petit peu mon interrogation
merci beaucoup merci monsieur laménie
monsieur lefebvre puis didier rambaud
oui madame ne présente messieurs les
ministres ma question concernait les pg
e mais bruno le maire a en partie
répondu puisque je faisais partie des
cosignataires
parmi les parlementaires qui avait
souhaité un étalement dans le
remboursement donc la donner des
éléments de réponse donc j'ai pas vu pas
plus de questions sur ce sujet merci
monsieur rendre au cuit jérôme bascher
merci madame la présidente
effectivement deux questions une son
plan de sortie de crise pour les
entreprises et dans la continuité
d'antoine faible sur les pe gg en tant
que j'ai entendu le président du medef
assez optimiste parlant de en gros de
chine 5% pas plus de 5% des entreprises
seraient en capacité de se ré en
capacité de rembourser leurs péchés est
ce que vous partagez cet optimiste
qu'est-ce que vous avez un regard
particulier là dessus
deuxième question effectivement
concernant des collectivités locales je
me réjouis de voir que ce plfr ouvre 200
millions d'euros de crédits nouveaux à
destination des collectivités locales
qui vont effectivement permettre de
respecter les engagements qui rend
compte qu'elle était pris par olivier
dussopt pain devant devant cela est
notamment de de compenser les pertes de
pertes de recettes des régies je
confirme qu'elle sujet dtsp 1 qu'il faut
qu'il faudra qu'ils nous sommes pas
encore à un petit trou encore à régler
sinon plus globalement on a eu hier dans
l'hémicycle un débat sur les
conséquences de la crise sur les
finances des collectivités locales pas
se cacher qu'il ya un débat
effectivement avec des divergences avec
peut-être des associations d'élus qui
dramatise un peu
aujourd'hui la situation financière des
collectivités locales est ce que
hollywood ssup nous nous faire peut-être
un point précis effectivement
aujourd'hui sur l'état des finances des
finances locales
à l'issue de cette crise merci jérôme
bascher et suivront jean michel arnaud
et thierry cozic merci madame la
présidente pêcher des ministres où elle
milliards de jean launay pour la poste
le gouvernement a réclamé un rapport
pour la bosse et les services it vercel
postale et il manque 1 milliards dans
les caisses au moins un milliard un
milliard 3 et la compensation et de
vendée dans le rapport que vous avez de
voir des vous même
dès cette année dès cette année or
peut-être est-ce prévu pour une loi de
finances rectificative vivante qui
m'amène à ma seconde question y
aura-t-il un plan de relance de après le
plan de soutien jean michel arnaud oui
mais dans le président monsieur le
ministre je reviens sur le dispositif
qui été longuement commenté déjà par mon
collègue delcros de de compensation des
recettes des pertes de recettes sur la
régie je voulais savoir puisque
visiblement dans la découverte du texte
on vise essentiellement les pertes de
recettes 2020 or dans les secteurs très
touristique pour ne pas dire ultra
touristique
les quatre mois cinq mois d'absence
d'exploitation sur l'exercice 2021 met
en danger
fortement l'activité d'un certain nombre
de régies à titre d'illustration les
bains du monêtier les bains commune de
serre chevalier dans les hautes-alpes se
retrouve particulièrement difficultés et
j'aimerais savoir effectivement de
quelle manière les cinq premiers mois de
l'année 2021 faut être pris en compte
puisque le texte actuellement dans le
cadre du projet de loi finances
rectificative ne concerne que les pertes
de 2020 deuxième sujet rapidement
j'aimerais avoir des précisions
concernant les 350 millions d'euros
affectés dans le cadre la proposition
pourrait faire aux compensations liées
aux événements particulièrement
compliqué pour les exploitations
agricoles dont j'ai cru comprendre que
350 millions d'euros c'était à la fois
pour la grippe aviaire est la fois pour
les supports végétaux que sont la vigne
et l'arboriculture
j'aimerais avoir effectivement une
ventilation
s'il est possible de la voir de ces
crédits envisagé et je rappelle que
cette somme paraît particulièrement
faible au vu de l'impact
particulièrement important et
significatif de pères d'exploitation sur
la viticulture française et sur
l'arboriculture et je rappelle également
que le plan de relance a totalement
exclu ou quasiment exclue
l'arboriculture sur la nécessaire
modernisation de ses activités et
j'aimerais savoir également si vous avez
prévu
et s'il est prévu dans le cadre du plan
de relance la possibilté de flécher sur
la borie culture française quelques
crédits merci thierry cozic et ensuite
sophie taille et paulhan merci merci
messieurs les ministres il ya une
première question sur la poste que je
souhaitais posée mais qui a été soulevée
par jérôme bascher je jouais à plier
donc d'après mes informations il ya des
mesures de soutien à la poste qui
auraient été envisagées ils ne sont pas
intégrés dans le texte
est ce qu'il ya une raison à cela est-ce
que vous pouvez vous nous en dire
davantage sur ce point deuxième sujet
vous évoqué la nécessité de sortie
progressive des aides publiques pour le
tissu économique et vous la mort c'est
relativement timidement dans ce plfr et
envisagez vous un réel débat
parlementaire sur ce sujet fondamental
je vous avoue mes craintes à ce stade
quand j'entends les propos du ministre
de l'économie qui sont bien plus
restrictif que ce que préconisent les
autorités économiques avec un risque
comme cela s'est produit en 2008 de quai
sur la reprise
donc ma question est celle-ci quel est
précisément votre stratégie d'ensemble
et pourrons nous en débattre les
derniers sujets où vous y faites
allusion seulement alors que ce sujet
est majeur
quelle est votre stratégie de réduction
de la dette et du déficit pour les
années à venir
allez vous poursuivre dans votre volonté
de réduction de la voilure des services
publics et de contraction de la dépense
où allez vous comme le préconise de
nombreux organismes économiques
si vous me permettez l'expression qu'on
peut pas franchement pas qualifié de
gauchiste de travailler sur la justice
fiscale et la juste contribution de
chacun comme le préconise groupe
socialiste depuis maintenant plus d'un
an
merci merci et sofitel et polluant sera
la dernière intervenante en je vais
couper puisque la liste s'allonge de
manière à donner la possibilité aux deux
ministres de pouvoir répondre merci
madame la présidente trois questions
hier question mon collègue soizic disait
que effectivement il ya un
accompagnement progressif de l'activité
économique pour la reprise qui donc va
être progressivement je lis dans le
rapport mais on n'a pas eu beaucoup le
temps de travailler vu le délai de
transmission que là il ya une
prolongation des aides pour les
travailleurs indépendants mais qui sera
uniquement pour ceux dont l'activité est
encore fermée administrativement est ce
que là il y aurait pas quand même un
intérêt a aussi fait rempart ce que les
travailleurs indépendants va faire appel
je dirai au fur et à mesure de la
reprise et de la montée en puissance des
activités
donc je comprends pas bien pourquoi d'un
côté c'est uniquement réduit à cela et
de l'autre côté c'est plus progressif
deuxième question marginale mais qui m'a
posé quand même interrogation il ya une
majoration du taux de réduction de
l'impôt sur les revenus pour des dons
aux associations cultuelles pourquoi là
pourquoi maintenant et troisième
question qui n'est pas directement lié
au texte mais qui est lié à l'actualité
récente et qui est lui et à la volonté
de bonne gestion des deniers publics qui
nous qui nous préoccupe tous et toutes
il ya une alerte d'une intersyndicale
dénonçant une future admission en non
valeur de 28% des contentieux douanier
liés au transfert de missions fiscales
de la direction générale des douanes
vers la direction générale de la des
législatives et fip
or il semble que vous ayez répandue que
pas du tout que c'était une fausse
information
mais quand je lis les déclarations dans
la presse je lis que quand même il y
aurait des dispositions qui conduiront à
modifier les règles de recouvrement des
créances faisant que certaines sommes
pour être in fine et ne pas être
recouvrées donc où est la vérité est qu
est-ce qui va être réellement mis en
place et quelles sont les perspectives
les prospectives en la matière de ses
et de ces contentieux douanier qui
pourrait ne pas aller au bout
merci merci mais c'est les ministres
avec des sujets variés l'agriculture la
poste les contentieux douanier
merci beaucoup aussi de répondre dans le
détail après je dois malheureusement
vous quittez l'olivier du soft fort la
suite alors sur simplification de la d61
je pense qu'olivier vous répondra sur
les questions posées par antoine lefèvre
et didier rambaud sur les pg e et des
entreprises qui restent en difficulté
nous notre évaluation qui est celle de
la banque de france pas tout à fait
précis c'est que vous avez de 5 à 7% de
l'entreprise dont la dette a augmenté et
dont trésorerie a diminué au cours de
cette période de crise si on voit le
verre à moitié plein ça veut dire vous
avez à peu près 95 % des entreprises et
qu'ils n'auront pas de difficulté à
rembourser ces paisibles mais ils font
comme stratégie a consisté à trouver une
réponse sur mesure pour chacun c'est ce
qui nous a amenés à maintenir l'ensemble
des dispositifs qui apporte un soutien
financier aux entreprises et à mettre en
place ce plan de transition avec la
possibilité d'apporter des fonds propres
aux entreprises qui en auraient besoin
et l'accélération des procédures
judiciaires doit permettre de traiter
l'étalement supplémentaires dp je le
rappelle dans le cadre d'une procédure
de redressement judiciaire
mais dans ce cadre là le juge pourra
décider la prolongation du pge au delà
des six ans et nous maintiendrons la
garantie de l'état c'était le point dur
qui était en cours de négociation avec
la commission européenne et que nous
avons obtenue sur les questions qui ont
été posées qui nous ont été posées sur
la poste
c'est le nez nous avons mis un très bon
rapport mais c'est un rapport qui le
mérite de mettre très clairement sur la
table la question de rythme de
l'attribution du courrier de livraison
de courrier
les pertes que ça représente pour la
poste et la nécessité d'adapter en
profondeur le service postal
aujourd'hui ça n'est tout simplement pas
tenable le volume d'envois de lettres de
courrier est en chute libre et chacun le
voit bien je pense à pratique
quotidienne qu'il faut adapter
structurellement le dispositif moi je
pense qu'il est bon de prendre le temps
de débattre ce cas c'est ce que nous
avons proposé avec le prêt ministe
prendre le temps de regarder ses
propositions en discuter avec vous ça
nous inscrirons ensuite les
compensations nécessaires jérôme bascher
m'a posé la question il y aura
évidemment de compensation mais avant de
parler argent
je pense qu'il faut d'abord par les
services publics laquelle service public
de la poste
voulons-nous dans les années à venir
quelle régularité quel rythme de service
mais c'est ça qu'ils en rapport le nec
mais d'être discutée s'agissant du plan
de relance 2 je recommande vivement de
mettre en oeuvre le plan de relance 1 le
plus vite possible et c'est exactement
ce que nous faisons
je suis quand même toujours stupéfait
par cette manif nous avons dès lors
qu'on à voter et décider quelque chose
immédiatement de se projeter sur quelque
chose de nouveau
le plus difficile n'est pas d'inventer
systématiquement quelque chose de
nouveau
le plus difficile c'est d'appliquer ce
qui a été décidé et je pense que c'est
ça qu'attendent nos compatriotes c'est
s'assurer que l'argent pour les pistes
cyclables pour la décarbonation des
entreprises pourraient digitalisation
des pme pour la transformation des
bâtiments pour la réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre sont
effectivement adoptés que l'argent
arrive dans les territoires dans les
ménages et dans les entreprises
c'est mon travail quotidien et je fais
le point toutes les semaines avec ce qu
est un général en charge du plan de
relance pour m'assurer que le
décaissement du plan de relance est
efficace
par ailleurs une loi sans que ces 100
milliards d'euros sont bien calibré et
qui correspondent au montant que était
nécessaire pour faire redémarrer
l'économie française les mots ont un
sens un plan de relance est là pour
relancer l'économie n'est pas là pour
mettre l'économie sous perfusion en
permanence or si l'on en croit les
chiffres qui sont ceux du fonds
monétaire international l'osce et de la
commission européenne et d'autres
instituts statistiques
nous sommes dans la bonne direction et
la relance
marsh france relance marche marche bien
il marche vite nous avons déjà engagé
près de 35 milliards d'euros et 100
milliards nous allons toucher l'argent
européen au mois de juillet grâce à la
pression que nous avons misé sur le
partenaire européen faut qu'ils adoptent
la décision aux sources propres donc le
plan de relance est en cours d'exécution
et va nous permettre effectivement
d'avoir le chiffre de croissance que
nous souhaitions en 2021
ensuite la vraie question qui se pose
c'est est ce qu'il faudra deux des
investissements plus importants
et là c'est pas de la relance dont il
s'agit c'est des investissements dans un
certain nombre de technologies qui sont
critiques pour permettre à la france et
à l'union européenne de faire jeu égal
avec la chine
hériter états unis parce qu'une fois
qu'on a relancé la machine économique et
qu'on a retrouvé le niveau d'activité
début 2000 22 que nous avions avant la
crise
c'est déjà un exploit je tiens à
souligner que si nous arrivons à cet
exploit c'est parce que nous avons fait
ce choix stratégique de protéger nos
capacités de production de protéger nos
compétences entreprises industrielles
qui redémarre aujourd'hui ses
compétences elles sont disponibles elles
sont là parce qu'on les a protégés et
l'entreprise n'a pas fermé les revenir
aux niveaux d'activité d'avant crise
pour la france comme pour tous les états
européens
ça veut dire revenir à un niveau de
croissance structurellement inférieur à
celui des etats-unis et de la chine
on peut s'en satisfaire ou pas par nous
et le présent la république nous en
satisfaisons pas et c'est la question
que j'ai posée à mes partenaires
européens mais est-ce qu'on profite de
cette crise pour
remettre à niveau et augmenter notre
potentiel de croissance pour nous avec
le présent la république
la réponse est oui ou est-ce que nous
nous contentons de revenir au statu quo
ante et très concrètement au delà de ce
choix stratégique
ce kit poser comme question c'est ce que
nous voulons avoir notre propre
constellation en orbite basse pour est
ce que nous dépendons en matière de
constellation en orbite basse des
américains ou de la chine
très concrètement c'est savoir si en
terme de semi conducteurs qui sont de
pétrole du 20e siècle mais qui sont
aussi indispensables l'industrie
qu'était le pétrole au 20e siècle
est-ce que je sois les semi conducteurs
les plus miniaturisés
nous dépendons de taïwan ou des
etats-unis où est ce que nous avons
notre propre fabrication de semi
conducteurs d'une taille inférieure à 28
ou 20 nanomètres
si nous voulons être indépendant mais il
faudra remettre de l'argent
ça veut dire est-ce que sur
l'intelligence artificielle est ce que
sur le cloud
est-ce que sur la santé est ce que sur
les biotechnologies il faut investir
plus pour avoir la garantie d'être au
même niveau que la chine ou que les uteq
c'est cette question là qui va s'opposer
à partir de la rentrée et sur laquelle
nous travaillons à la demande du présent
la république avec mes équipes
d'arrache-pied parce que c'est une vraie
question stratégique pour la france et
c'est une vraie str restions stratégique
pour le continent européen je pense que
cette crise peut être une opportunité
pour nous d'augmenter le potentiel de
croissance de la france et du continent
européen
donc ce n'est pas d'un plan de relance
dont il s'agit mais bien
d'investissements supplémentaires pour
augmenter le potentiel de croissance de
la france et de l'ordre s'agissant des
compensations agricole je pense
qu'olivier du soft répondra débat
parlementaire sur les aides bien sûr je
pense que le débat
pfr il doit servir justement à
discuter les choix que nous avons fait
on nous a demandé beaucoup de temps
beaucoup de dialogue avec les
entreprises concernées par exemple le
fonds de solidarité
nous avons fait un choix qui a demandé
des semaines et des semaines de
discussions et d'arbitrage pour savoir
si on maintenait le fond tel qu'il était
aussi le modifier pour le rendre plus
précis plus ciblées et en même temps
dégressif ont fait le deuxième choix
qu'on n'a pas maintenu à fonctionnalités
pour tout le monde sans distinction en
ile-de-france solidarité il est d'abord
pour les entreprises les plus touchées
par la crise et on va permettre à des
entreprises qui redémarre mais qui
redémarre pas dans des conditions
normales à resteront jolie ne redémarre
pas dans les conditions normales ya que
sa terrasse couverte et demain il y aura
aucune partie sa salle donc il va perdre
de l'argent il faut qu'ils rachètent des
fournitures ça lui coûte cher
donc il a besoin du fonds de solidarité
et ce sera dégressif heroes démarre en
juin il a une somme plus importante 40%
de sa perte de serre par rapport à 2010
9 en juillet il aura déjà bien
redémarrer c'est plus que 30 mai en août
ce sera plus peu vain parce que
normalement il sera revenu à la normale
et à la fin du mois d'août
on fera le bilan pour voir si cela
correspondait bien à la demande des
entreprises
enfin sa question de sophie tablier de
la majoration du crédit d'impôt de la
réduction d'impôt pour les associations
cultuelles
la réalité c'est que toutes ces
associations cultuelles et
l'établissement public des cultes
reconnus d'alsace moselle pour être tout
à fait précis ont perdu beaucoup de
recettes au cours de l'année passée à
cause des règles sanitaires
l'évaluation qui est fait par exemple
par l'église catholique ces seules
données dont on dispose c'est que les
deux confirmant les 2020 ont provoqué
une perte de 90 millions d'euros c'est à
dire pas loin de 20 % des recettes
courantes de l'église catholique
donc ils ont demandé l'ensemble de ces
associations cultuelles d'avoir une
majoration du taux du crédit d'impôt qui
sera porté à 75 %
c'est ce qui vous est proposé ici
sachant que évidemment pour tous les
crédits d'impôt
il est plafonné et que cette mesure
serait exceptionnelle et limitée à deux
ans merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
du socle monsieur ministre merci
monsieur le président que quelques mots
d'abord pour et pardonnez moi c'est un
peu dans le désordre mais pour revenir
sur la question des 350 millions d'euros
consacrés à l'agriculture
c'est une première tranche pour
atteindre un seul objectif que
l'objectif fixé par le premier ministre
d'une indemnisation des dégâts du gel à
hauteur d'un milliard d'euros sachant
que nous connaîtrons la nature et
l'ampleur exacte des dégâts et les
pertes d exploitation au fur et à mesure
des dates de récolte il ya aussi une
saisonnalité en matière de recettes pour
les exploitations agricoles et dont tu
es 350 millions nous permettent d'y
faire face ils nous permettent aussi de
faire face au financement de l'aide aux
bovins allaitants pour une soixantaine
de millions d'euros à l'indemnisation de
la grippe aviaire
ainsi que de la jaunisse de la betterave
pour les mêmes menton un complément des
aides au stockage qui colle pour 10
millions d'euros et à renforcer cela
revient à la question du gel
le fonds des calamités agricoles
nous avons encore à travailler pour
préciser l'ampleur du dégâts et
l'ampleur des pertes avec ses 350
millions d'euros
nous sommes en capacité de faire face
pour les premiers engagements et donc de
les tenir
je précise aussi que pour ce qui
concerne l'agriculture le premier
ministre a annoncé un doublement de
l'enveloppé consacrée aux
investissements pour l'adaptation aux
évolutions climatiques
et si ce doublement de l'envelope ne
trouve pas de traductions dans le plfr
que nous représentons c'est tout
simplement parce que nous pouvons le
faire par voie réglementaire
dans le cadre de la gestion des crédits
de la mission consacrée au plan de
relance
je précise pour m'aider à me tailler
polluant que le bénéfice du fonds
solidarité dans les conditions indiquées
par bruno le maire pour les travailleurs
indépendants est possible dès lors
qu'ils remplissent une des conditions
qui s'impose à toutes les entreprises
indépendants ou non c'est la perte
d'activité de 50 % puisque depuis
novembre 2020
l'ouverture du fonds de solidarité à
toutes les entreprises a été acté mais
ce conditions de perte d'activité l'an
clés pour vous rassurer sur ce point là
vous dire aussi avant de devenir avec
caisson et collectivités locales que
pour ce qui concerne les transferts de
recouvrement et notamment le passage de
la direction générale des douanes la
direction générale des finances
publiques d'un certain nombre d'éléments
fiscalité je conteste absolument tout ce
qui a été écrit dans les articles de
presse que vous avez mentionné
il n'y aura pas d'abandon de créances
massif l'état n'abandonnera pas
d'expérience qui ont été qui sont
importantes et qui lui sont dus nous
travaillons effectivement à une
harmonisation non pas des modalités de
recouvrement puisqu'il ya un transfert
et la dgesip mettre en oeuvre des
modalités de recouvrement traditionnels
là où nous devons travailler à une
harmonisation
c'est sur les modalités de recouvrement
forcé puisque parmi les recouvrements
que la dg philippe doit faire en lieu et
place de la direction générale de la
douane au fur et à mesure des transferts
de taxes ou de fiscalité il ya des
recouvrements forcés pour des gens qui
n'ont tout simplement pas payés qu'ils
accusent des retards les modalités de
recouvrement forcé sont différentes et
nous allons les harmoniser par contre
nous ne renonçons pas évidemment aux
créances que qu'elle est un as sur un
certain nombre d'acteurs et en termes
d'efficacité du recouvrement
les chiffres dont nous disposons sont
rassurants pour tous les éléments de
fiscalité ou de taxes ont été transférés
de la dgddi vers la dg philippe la
performance l'efficacité la dgesip est
avérée je ne prend qu'une illustration
la tva sur le pétrole qui a fait l'objet
d'un transfert de recouvrement depuis le
1er janvier et la première échéance
déclarative de janvier affichent un taux
de recouvrement de 99 2% pour un peu
moins de 890 millions d'euros
c'est très exactement ce que nous
visions et cela démontre mais d'autres
exemples sur d'autres éléments de
fiscalité que nous ne perdons pas en
efficace et de l'efficacité de
recouvrement en passant d'une
administration à l'autre
je précise aussi même si ça ne concerne
pas la fiscalité que parfois les
mouvements sont inverses ou d'autres
directions la direction générale de la
douane
je pense notamment une expérimentation
que nous menons
que nous mènerons pas sur le port du
havre en matière de transfert des
contrôles effectués par la dgccrf vers
la direction générale des douanes pour
limiter le nombre d'intervenants gagnant
fidélité mais aussi en efficacité des
contrôles sur les questions relatives
aux collectivités territoriales la
situation des collectivités
territoriales telle que nous la
connaissons pour 2020 désormais les
comptes sont arrêtés et une situation
qui est dégradée par rapport à 2010 9
mai qui comparativement à l'état et la
sécurité sociale est extrêmement
préserver la diminution des recettes de
fonctionnement des collectivités
je parle évidemment manière très
macroéconomique est autour d'un pour
cent et l'évolution des dépenses de
fonctionnement est limité à 0 25%
nous avons même une forme de surprise à
la lecture de certains chiffres
lorsque l'on regarde les communes de
moins de 3500 habitants 91% d'entre
elles ont vu leur capacité d'épargné
brut augmenter entre 2019 et 2020 parce
que leurs dépenses ont diminué plus
fortement que leurs recettes
alors même que les communes de plus
grande taille ont pu et ont été amenés à
mettre en oeuvre des dépenses notamment
sanitaires plus importante à la fin
d'exercice
l'épargné brute des collectivités
s'élève à 31 5 milliards d'euros c'est
le montant de 2018 et les aides
exceptionnelles à l'investissement que
nous apportons aux collectivités font
que les aides supplémentaires qu'on
pense d'une certaine manière assez
largement la perte d' épargne brute
entre 2019 et 2020
les parcs brut des communes et des
intercommunalités a baissé de 7 5%
là aussi des choses qui sont parfois
étonnantes nous nous sommes beaucoup
inquiété collectivement de la situation
des communes de des communes de montagne
et les intercommunalités de montagne et
nous constatons que la houle
la baisse moyenne de l'épargné brute des
communes et des interconnexions la
baisse de l'épargné brute des communes
et des intercommunalités de montagne est
limitée à 2000 5 % parce que les
mécanismes de protection et notamment
les mécanismes de garantie de recettes
fiscales ont été plus efficient le prix
mobilisés pour les collectivités qui ont
des structures de recettes fiscales
particulières
c'est à dire caractérisée par la taxe de
séjour la taxe sur les casinos et la
taxe sur les remontées mécaniques et ce
sont ces trois éléments de fiscalité qui
ont été les plus dégradés et donc les
plus protégés par la mise en oeuvre des
mécanismes de compensation dont nous
avions discuté ensemble toujours manière
macroéconomique et quand on regarde la
totalité des dépenses et de recettes de
fonctionnement et d'investissement des
collectivités en 2019 les collectivités
affiché un solde positif d'un milliard
de en 2020
l'effet ciseau légère effet ciseau que
j'ai évoqués amen et collectivités a
affiché un solde à l' équilibre et le
solde attendu pour 2021 est positif à 1
milliard 5 ce qui signifie que si nos
prévisions s'avèrent justes et parfois
proches qu'elles sont entreprenantes
le solde des collectivités en 2021 sera
très légèrement supérieur au sol des
collectivités en 2019 dans tout le monde
s'accordait à dire que c'était plutôt
une bonne année pour les finances
locales qui avait été par ailleurs
marquée par la reprise de
l'investissement
c'est ce qui m'amène à dire et parfois
apparaître obstiné sur la question de
l'aide l'investissement est à dire que
les dispositifs que nous avons mises en
oeuvre me semble suffisamment calibre et
protecteur à ce stade pour accompagner
et donner aux collectivités la
possibilité de participer au plan de
relance je n'en dis pas plus sur la
question des collectivités je pourrais
revenir en tout cas je je tenais tout
cas je l'espère être rassurant sur la
situation qu'elles connaissent
aujourd'hui et je précise pardon de ses
le président que les chiffres que jeunes
sont des chiffres macroéconomiques et
que évidemment il y avait des
différences et personne ne niera le fait
que les dépenses d'allocation
individuelles de solidarité ont été plus
importantes avec là aussi des
conséquences pour les départements ce
qui nous amène à des travaux spécifiques
et que la selon la nature des recettes
classées de la structure des recettes
des collectivités
les résultats peuvent être différents
pris individuellement merci monsieur le
ministre je vous propose d'ouvrir donc
notre dernière série de cinq questions
avec charles bonnet tout d'abord suivi
de pascal savoldelli merci monsieur le
président simplement monsieur le
ministre la question que j'ai posée a
été je vais dire les ses attendus auront
été excellemment développé par bernard
delcros donc je ne reviendrai pas sur
cet aspect mais si je pouvais plus c'est
monsieur le ministre dans ses re
derniers retranchements en ce qui
concerne le l'article 10 donc et la
compensation aux régies sur l'aspect
macro qu'il distingue justement dans
dans la proche des collectivités locales
est ce que l'état des lieux a été
effectivement bien appréhender et est ce
qu on est certain de l'adéquation en
fait de l' enveloppe et de la
problématique qui est en bas et si on
redescend au côté au plan micro hier
nous avons eu un débat avec joël giraud
dont on peut penser qu'il a eu quelques
unes qu'une certaine concertation avec
vous il a évoqué notamment des calculs
complexes et des collectivités plus
fragiles que les unes que les autres
est ce que à ce niveau vous avez prévu
quand même que les la main au niveau
départemental notamment au niveau des
défis et des fip est peut-être le cas
échéant des préfets pour mieux
appréhender ce type de situation merci
charles parce que savoldelli puis
jean-marie misson merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre nous
avait fait partager vos étonnement donc
je vais partager les miens puis on va
essayer de voir comment on conclut parce
que
sur les collectivités territoriales moi
j'ai un problème d'arbitrage y compris
dans mon vote comme parlementaire c'est
que j'ai la mf qui estime qu'à une perte
des recettes de l'ordre de 2 milliards
et et vous nous dites article 10 de 2,2
ce projet rectifier le financent que 200
millions ça ça répond la perte de
compensation là je vous avoue que bon il
peut y avoir des décalages y voilà et
moi je comprends dit dira bros nous dit
les associations d'élus dramatise au je
crois pas que les associations d'élus
d'ailleurs à tous les niveaux la mf
l'adf robert f
soit des associations qui manque de
responsabilité
là il ya un décalage il va falloir
expliquer quoi voilà je vous dis ça pour
parce que quand les speaks à éviter des
polémiques inutiles du style reproché
aux communes d'avoir augmenté leur taxe
foncière
ce qui était le cas de deux ministres le
maire qui a été dans l'obligation de
nous quitter après sûr aussi la façon
dont vous nous présenter votre analyse
de la situation
pas de dramatisation pas de
dramatisation ou vous évoquez ça je
trouve que c'est la force de vos propos
c'est quand même une épargne brute
monsieur le ministre que vous nous dites
qu'elle est quand même importante à 7,5
pour cent comparé aux autres chiffres
sur la bonne santé des collectivités moi
je serai peut-être une discussion plus
prudente
dernière chose c'est pour comprendre
mais vraiment je pose la question vous
avez mis si j'ai bien compris un
milliard en termes de valeur de vente en
fonction de vos besoins et je cite faire
face à d'éventuelles dépenses imprévues
moi je vous avoue peut-être par manque
d'expérience mais comment je fais comme
parlementaire pour voter pour ou contre
ou m'abstenir
quand le gouvernement dit il faut voter
un milliard
destiné à faire face à des dépenses
imprévues
à cette étape d'un cinquième plan de
finances rectificatif et à la veille de
la loi de finances oui si on pouvait
jouer un peu plus carte blanche enfin
voilà après on y voit plus clair et puis
on vote avec esprit de responsabilité
ainsi pascal jean marie visons puis
philippe dallier
merci monsieur le président chacun
convient la relance a besoin de tous
pour réussir et parmi ces tous il ya
notamment les collectivités locales
d'ailleurs je souscris totalement à la
remarque de ma collègue sylvie
vermeillet lorsqu'elle a évoqué il
rallonge de la tsr qui ont été
bienvenues
c'est pas exactement le chemin et qu'on
a pris lorsqu'on a voté en tout cas pour
ceux qui l'ont voté la loi de finances
pour 2011 21 ou a constaté le que le gel
des délibérations d'exonérations et
d'abattements en matière de taxe sur le
foncier bâti a été actée et que donc ça
la prive un certain nombre de communes
de recettes et alors que pour certains
particuliers ça présente un effet
d'aubaine particulier qui parfois
thésaurisent plutôt que dépenser
voilà les alors que les communes bien
sûr les collectivités territoriales de
manière générale s'empresse de réaliser
et d'investir demandé s'il était prévu
de revenir sur ce jeune monsieur le
ministre à l'occasion du projet d
prochain projet de loi de finances merci
jean marie et philippe dallier
merci monsieur le président j'ai mis un
mot une question alors un mot pour me
réjouir de
des 700 millions d'euros que le
gouvernement va rajouter pour
l'hébergement d'urgence et surtout de le
faire à ce moment là de l'année puisque
je rappelle que l'année dernière en 2001
il avait fallu attendre le plfr 4 donc
au mois de novembre pour ajouter 450
millions d'euros de crédits et qui
n'avait pas été suffisant pour boucler
l'année puisque il devait manquer encore
au moins 150 millions d'euros
supplémentaires
ceci dit les crédits que nous avons voté
en et les fit pour 2021 étaient
inférieurs à ceux consommés en 2020 et
donc alors 2 combien il ya 200 millions
d'euros d'écart mais comme leur base âge
n'avait pas été effectuée la question
que je serai de vous poser le show me c
est ce qu avec ces 700 millions d'euros
vous êtes certain de passer l'année dans
de bonnes conditions
et quand je dis dans de bonnes
conditions c'est pour faire en sorte que
les associations qui gèrent les places
qui vont être maintenues ouvertes à
cause de la crise du coc vide et bien
n'auront pas faire d' avance de
trésorerie pour le compte de l'état
voilà monsieur le ministre
quatre questions qui appellent vos
réponses
pardonnez moi merci messieurs prison
confirmant d'abord le l'enveloppent
destiné à la compensation des pertes de
régie je confirme au sénateur guinée que
l'estimation de 100 millions s'appuie
bien sûr un état des lieux
j'y reviendrai pour compléter la réponse
à la question pascal salvodelli par
rapport à la totalité des parts
tarifaires mais nous sommes à 200
millions d'euros
l'objectif que nous avons est
d'accompagner des régies qui n'ont pas
pu l'être jusqu'à présent certaines
régies organisé un service public
industriel et commercial ont recours de
manière classique dans le cadre d'une
organisation un budget annexe à des
salariés du privé dans ce cas là elles
ont été éligibles aux eaux
[Musique]
aux activités partielles il ya des
dispositifs d'aidé économique
d'autres régies sont organisées au sein
des budgets principaux bénéficier des
recettes de la collectivité et compris
des recettes fiscales et ont ainsi
bénéficié d'une protection de leur
niveau global de recettes au même titre
que celle de la collectivité
par contre nous avons des régies souvent
avec une nature industrielle et
commerciale mais organise un spa ou en
organisant ce pic mais avec des agents
droit public et avec parfois des
incohérences paix et je mesure le mot
incohérences entre la nature d'activité
la nature des recettes la nature des
contrats établis entre les agents droit
public droit privé et les capacités
contributives auprès de l'acoss et d'une
éthique selon les cas
quand je dis incohérences le moins
sévère d'autant plus qu'ils sont des
incohérences qui sont bien souvent
involontaire est en tout cas aucun
moment mise en oeuvre délibérément il
s'agit en réalité de stations de ski
souvent de petite taille s'agit de
stations thermales d'établissement de
thermo s'agit de grottes touristique
il s'agit d'équipements qui finalement
fonctionne depuis des décennies et parce
que ça toujours très bien fonctionner de
la manière dont s'est organisée personne
ne s'est jamais inquiété d'une
éventuelle incohérences entre eux
l'organisation juridique et la nature du
service et donc ce sont ces régies là
que nous souhaitons accompagner et il
est des 100 millions d'euros nous
paraissent suffisants et j'ajoute même
que dans le cadre de ces 200 millions
d'euros
nous pourrons intégrer à condition d'un
petit travail de d'amendements et deux
dans le cadre du débat parlementaire
nous pourrons intégrer un certain nombre
un petit nombre de régies qui ont
recours à des dsp comme je l'aï évoqué
tout à l'heure en réponse à madame
madame terme et c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que nous ne
sommes pas sur une logique de guichet
sommes véritablement sur une logique
avec des paramètres et des critères qui
permettra à l'état de connaître les
montants que nous allons verser aux
régies concernés par voie budgétaire il
ne s'agit pas de compensation ne s'agit
pas de prélèvements sur recettes c'est
de la subvention directe et donc nous ne
prévoyons pas de déconcentrer ce
dispositif au niveau des préfets puisque
il saura
totalement paramétré par contre bien
évidemment nous restons très attentive
et en même temps assez rassuré dans la
mesure où le nombre de communes et de
l'intercommunalité inscrits inscrits
dans les réseaux dallaire de la dgesip
reste tout à fait stable
que ce soit en france d'ailleurs ou non
m pas leur donner moins en métropole ou
dans les territoires d'outre-mer
c'est assez rassurant sur l'état global
des collectivités concernant la
comparaison que le sénateur fait nouveau
délit fait entre des chiffres annoncés
par certaines associations d'élus et les
200 millions d'euros les deux milliards
d'euros évoqué par la mer en particulier
concerne les pertes tarifaire hyper de
recettes tarifaires des collectivités
nous ne changeons pas de position nous
avons dit que nous compensons que nous
garantissons pardon les recettes
fiscales et domaniale des collectivités
en 2020 sur la base de la moyenne 2017
2019 dans le cadre du plf 2021 il a été
voté la reconduction de ce filet de
sécurité pour les recettes fiscales mais
sans jamais entrer sur le champ des
recettes tarifaires
j'ai eu l'occasion à plusieurs reprises
de dire que c'était budgétairement
massif pour l'état que par ailleurs les
recettes tarifaires et est souvent celle
qui avait comme contrepartie des
économies de constatation difficile à
mesurer et à trouver en termes de
justice et donc nous n'entrons pas dans
ce débat-là j'ajoute un élément ou je ne
sais pas si c'est un argument
évidemment je comprends que les
collectivités auraient préféré que l'on
compense les pertes de recettes
tarifaires mais comme je disais tout à
l'heure la situation financière des
collectivités comparativement à celle de
l'état et de la sécurité sociale est
véritablement très très protégé beaucoup
plus préservé et il est assez logique
d'une certaine manière que les trois
acteurs de l'action publique et donc de
la dépense publique que sont l'état la
sécurité sociale et les collectivités
locales puissent aussi contribuer à des
degrés différents
à la réponse à la crise que nous
connaissons jeu malgré tout continuer ou
aussi est de continuer à vous rassurer
d'abord en disant que oui l'épargné
brute
des communes et des intercommunalités
baisse de 7 5% entre 2019 et 2020 mais
en ayant en tête que 2019 s'est égaré
caractérisée par un niveau d'épargné
brute qui était considéré comme
exceptionnel par son importance donc les
baisses ne sont jamais agréables mais
vaut mieux baisser un peu lorsqu'on part
d'un point exceptionnellement haut
plutôt que lorsqu'on est dans une
situation difficile au préalable
toujours pour continuer sur cette
question des collectivités dire que une
des explications tant à la situation
2020 qu'à notre optimisme pour 2021
si au maintien des recettes fiscales
nous avions tous la crainte a été
extrêmement partagées de voir baisser le
dm théo de 20 ou 30%
il s'avère que de manière définitive
ils ont baissé de 2% pour les
départements et de 3 6% pour les
communes de la même manière nous
craignons un effondrement de la cvae en
2021 et le volume global de la cva
versés aux collectivités locales en 2021
va baisser seulement 10 est toujours
trop de 1 1% par rapport au volume de
cvae versés en 2020 donc j'entends que
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
une baisse de 20% mais ça reste je crois
particulièrement soutenable en tout cas
comparativement à ce que nous pouvons
nous pouvions craindre sur et pour finir
sur cette question des collectivités je
ne reviens pas même si monsieur c'est un
terme ils ont mis à mieux habiter sur la
question de la detr et de la nécessité
selon vous d'augmenter encore les
criques d'investissement je crois que
les éléments que j'ai donné tout à
l'heure sur le fait que ça me paraît de
nature
en tout cas pas suffisant pour soutenir
l'investissement des collectivités ont
déjà été données nous veillons par
contre parce que sur les questions de
fiscalité
les dates la pardonnez moi la durée des
périodes pendant lesquelles il y avait
un gel des taux soit strictement
conforme à ce qui avait été voté c'est à
dire l'année des bascules de fiscalité
pour qu'on puisse ensuite les
collectivités puissent retrouver de la
liberté de vote des taux et des
exonérations notamment pour la tfpb
concernant les communes
je précise qu' un certain nombre de
rôles complémentaires sont en cours
d'enregistrement pour faire en sorte que
la compensation à laquelle nous nous
sommes engagés soit absolument parfaite
il ya quelques rôles qui accuse une
forme de retard ce qui peut pénaliser
les collectivités concernées donc nos
services sont mobilisés pour rattraper
ses retards
enfin deux dernières questions une
question du sénateur d'allier sur les
700 millions d'euros
ça nous paraît justement calibré et nous
faisons le choix de le voter maintenant
de proposer au parlement de voter pardon
pour éviter les phénomènes que vous avez
décrit est vécue l'an dernier dans le
pire des cas nous pourrions ajouter des
crédits dans la loi de fins de gestion
mais ce n'est pas notre objectif et 700
millions d'euros nous par ailleurs un
chiffre suffisant enfin pour répondre
aux sénateurs salvodelli sur la dotation
pour les dépenses accidentelle et
imprévus qui est une méthode et un outil
prévu par la lolf que nous n'avons pas
dit comment est ce que je peux voter un
milliard envie de vous dire dans un
sourire ça tombe bien puisque nous
proposons un milliard cinq et dans un
second sourire je rappelle que l'an
dernier ont été les fers 2 le parlement
avait voté une bd est de 1 milliard six
dont il ya une forme de précédents
pourquoi est ce que nous proposons
d'inscrire une réserve de précaution 2
milliards 5
est ce que le plf que nous voulons pas
les faire que nous vous présentons sera
promulguée et si tout se passe bien
autour de la mi juillet que nous
espérons que tout se passe bien pendant
l'été dans produits sanitaires d'un
point de vue économique mais que si nous
étions confrontés à des besoins en
termes de dépenses imprévues et inconnu
ce jour nous avons besoin de se refaire
manière d'avoir cette précaution parce
que d'une part nous ne pourrions pas
réunir le parlement avant la rentrée et
donc nous aurons cette difficulté là est
par ailleurs cela a été rappelé par le
rapporteur général
nous avons pris un décret d'avancé qui
est important qu'ils frôlent et 1 % des
crédits ouverts ce qui signifie que la
technique du décret dalens ne peut pas
être utilisé une seconde fois cette
année
donc cette réserve de précaution dont
nous rendrons évidemment content de son
utilisation si elles devaient être
mobilisés nous permet dans un objectif
de prudence de voir paris
été et d'anticiper en tout cas de nous
prémunir contre des dépenses que nous ne
serions prévoir au moment de l'examen du
plf
[Musique]